each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you for coming my name is Amy
Draves and I'm here to welcome Douglas
stone to the Microsoft Research visiting
speaker series doug is here to discuss
his book Einstein in the quantum in
which he examines Einsteins early career
and foundation in quantum mechanics he
is the Carl a Morse professor and chair
of the applied physics department at
Yale and has been the recipient of
several awards and honors including the
Alfred P sloan fellowship rhodes
scholarship and the presidential young
and young investigator award please join
me in giving him a very warm welcome
well thank you Amy for inviting me and
you know this is a small room do I need
the microphone for the people online how
I do okay too bad because I hope I'm not
blasting them out I'll try to talk I get
excited in my voice elevates so it's a
pleasure to be here to talk about this
book I'm a first-time author I'm
actually mainly an active of physicist
doing work theoretical work relating to
lasers and micro electronics but I had
this previous existence as an undergrad
and as a master's student studying
philosophy and things like that and so I
got an opportunity which I'll tell you
about to sort of exercise that part of
my brain in writing a book for popular
audiences which is something I've wanted
to do for a long time but I didn't know
whether people would be that interested
in PT symmetric wave equations so I
couldn't figure out how to do a popular
book on that but this seemed a little
more accessible or at least a more
general interest so ok so i'm going to
say today in my lecture how did I come
to write this book why write another
book on Einstein there are thousands of
books on
einstein and some of them are actually
pretty good and after explaining those
things i'll just give you a flavor of
some of the dramatic episodes in the
history of science that actually got me
excited to write this book which are not
as well known as the episodes recounted
in those thousand other books and i'll
say a little bit about what einstein was
like one of the fun things in this
project was that i was able to read all
his letters from essentially 1896 up to
the the 1920s those are the ones that
are all published and translated in his
papers you really get a sense of what
kind of person he was and then finally
many of you may know that the thing
that's most famous about einstein in
quantum theory is that he didn't like it
that he actually refused to work on it
and remained a doubter that it was the
complete truth until the end of his
career until he died in the in the 50s
so so the the actual subject of this
book is somewhat surprising because it's
all about how fundamental his
contributions actually word a quantum
theory so so this came about because i
was working in a branch of modern
quantum theory called quantum chaos
where you try to understand how chaotic
systems that would classically behave in
this strange unstable way actually
interact with the laws of quantum
mechanics and what the manifestations
are of that chaos and my PhD student
shown here hakan trichy now professor at
Princeton was trying to write the
introduction to his thesis and he was
having trouble explaining the
fundamental essence of this problem and
I said you know I heard that Einstein
wrote something about this in 1917 so
you know maybe Einstein can solve our
problem so and it is true that he wrote
a paper in 1917 that's relatively
obscure I talked a little bit about it
in the
book but it's a little bit too technical
a little it's not a historic paper but
it's a fabulous paper which has been
misunderstood and I read that paper and
we ended up actually using Einstein's
approach to explain what was going on
with this problem and I found myself
thinking for the first time in a long
time wow this guy was really a genius
right this is very minor paper for
Einstein but for me it would have been
you know courier shaping paper and it's
a little bit like Beethoven I'm going to
come back to at the end where you know
you just take him for granted you know
you don't really think about him if
you're a composer into 21st century
you're not you're not necessarily you
learned about Beethoven a long time ago
and haven't thought about him too much
so because I studied this one paper and
then wrote this article explaining it in
physics today I knew this tiny little
corner of Einstein's were but it was two
thousand five and two people here know
what was special about two thousand five
someone must know you had right so it
was the hundredth anniversary of his
so-called annus mirabilis miracle year
when he wrote four papers that
revolutionized physics and so they had a
big celebration it was the world year of
physics and there was sort of a run on
people they could talk about Einstein
and so they even got down to people like
me who you know I said we know this one
little paper guys but they didn't want
to hear about that one little paper so I
had to cram on Einstein in quantum
mechanics and as i did this cramming so
i could talk about something more
general i came to this stunning
realization okay so i will concede that
Einstein has received a reasonable
amount of attention in the scholarly
literature and the media literature
nonetheless I came to the realization
that he doesn't get enough credit which
is pretty shocking at least this
Einstein the 1905 guy who I really like
doesn't get as much credit so
actually eventually I didn't still plan
to write a book but then after I gave a
few talks people kept saying well where
can i buy your book and so anyway the
rest is semi history okay so the reason
this is so important is that quantum
mechanics is a turning point that the
discovery or the invention have you want
to put it off quantum theory in quantum
mechanics is a turning point in human
civilization basically around 1900
physics had run in chemistry had run
into this fundamental roadblock we
didn't really understand the laws that
govern the atom okay so all of science
had been culminating to this point where
either we were going to be able to
understand the unseen realm of the atom
or we weren't and for a while it was in
doubt it took 26 years it basically
started in nineteen hundred and was
until 1926 that um that it was more or
less the big breakthrough occurred and
as late as 1924 people were despairing
and I actually read in my studies people
saying you know maybe humans who evolved
to you know hunt mastodons on the
savannas just are not capable of
understanding the atom there's no reason
that we are necessarily going to be able
to understand this unseen realm but it
turned out we were able to so the fact
that the most famous physicist in
history actually played this key role
which is not appreciated makes this I
think an interesting book in the history
of ideas and of course as people here
will know the success in understanding
the Adam unleash the technologies of the
twentieth and twenty-first centuries so
and just one example relevant to what
everybody here probably is involved with
is old versus new electronics basically
we understood a lot about electricity
and magnetism in the 19th century and we
could make components like this this is
a transistor you know about an inch or
two long with based on a vacuum tube and
then we could gang them together and we
can make an amplifier or something like
that with this but the big change came
in the 40s and 50s when we started to
understand how to build electronics at
the micro and even Nana
scale where this is now the same kind of
device a transistor but on this hundred
nanometer scale of modern printed
integrated circuits so to understand how
to build electronic devices into a
material at the microscale we absolutely
had to know the laws of quantum
mechanics in the quantum structure of
matter okay so let me start with a
little biographical information about
Einstein some of you may be big buffs
other views others of you may not be so
he was born in 1879 to an aspiring
somewhat struggling middle-class secular
non-religious Jewish family they there
were as engineers and the family that an
engineering firm this was in um geminii
where he was born he was educated in
munich till age 14 and he was an
excellent student unlike the urban
legends I'll go into that more if you're
interested but he always had this kind
of slightly superior look to him that
annoyed his authoritarian German
teachers one of them the Latin teacher
Dagon heart said told him that he better
you know shape up and Einstein said you
know I haven't said anything you know
and the Dagon heart said your mere
presence here in the class undermines
the classes respect for me so something
about the way he was behaving with
respect to authority would persist
through life was showing up there and I
think he really was probably a bit of a
pain as a student having read all these
letters and incidents okay so at age 14
he actually just drops out no you know
unbeknownst to his parents who have
moved to Italy because their engineering
venture has failed in Munich he shows up
on their doorstep nice to his family
brilliant son he's dropped out of school
what's going on to you you know so so he
says don't worry don't worry I have a
plan you don't need a high school degree
to go to the Zurich Polytechnic which is
now the ETH in Zurich and he would just
study himself which he did and
the entrance exams so he tries the first
time and he actually excels in math and
physics and would have passed he's only
16 so he's two years younger than they
normally except he does very well he
doesn't do so well in history and french
and so on so he technically fails and
then he goes to another year of
schooling and then he gets in okay and
for the first two years he's the top
student in the physics section and he's
very popular with the the professors and
then something changes he realizes that
they're not going to teach him about the
modern developments in physics
particularly about electromagnetic
theory which he's very interested in so
he stops going to class his performance
plummets I love the anecdote where in in
the in the experimental class they hand
them a chit or a instruction sheet and
he would not look at it and he would
walk over and then just drop it in the
wastebasket and then try to do the
experiment without looking and he
eventually did cause an explosion in the
lab and so on so he got it he failed
that class and so he barely gets his
degree and he's refused an assistance
position and Hinrich vapor who was the
head of the physics division who had
initially really supported him was so
mad at him that he engaged to
engineering students as the his
assistant instead of hiring Einstein so
he's essentially almost kicked out of
academia there while he was at the
Polytechnic he falls in love with his
classmate maleva marriage a Serbian
woman very unusual to have a woman
student in the class and there they are
at their marriage photo in 1903 and they
have three children but eventually their
marriage falls apart in 1913 when
Einstein is wooed away to Berlin after
many things of much has happened that I
will get to and eventually they're
divorced in 1918 for the next two years
he's literally penniless he eats out a
living doing giving private lessons and
then he finally gets a job at the famous
patent the famous job at the Patent
Office in barren because his friend
gross
father has pole there but he never gets
discouraged if there's this quote in the
letter of the letters of the time I am a
cheerful fellow and have no talent
whatsoever for melancholic moods now
another thing that he's just such an
abelian character that really attracted
me one thing that I got a kick out of is
that he used to sign his letters to his
wife with this sobriquet the valiant
swabian he says say the valiant swabian
is not a afraid well so his family is
from Swabia which is a region in germany
and there's this there's this poem about
a crusader night d vacariu schwäbisch
rather one of something like that who is
somehow the heroic essence of what it
means to be a sway bein and he would
sign his letters that way a little bit
like someone signing their lee letters
Indiana Jones or something like that so
so he had this kind of very outgoing and
I don't know just sort of a lot of joie
de vivre his life here's a picture of
him as a student at age 19 at ETH he
sort of looks like that there and then
this is a little bit later in 1904 with
his first son Hans Albert and maleva
okay so now let me talk a little bit
about the science that's a little
overview of the biography and I can
certainly tell you more later if you're
interested but let's talk about the
science so in 1900 Max Planck begins the
quantum era and I'm going to you know go
to that episode shortly that's the
episode that started me working on the
book in 1905 we have the miracle year
I'm putting down quanta of light special
relativity in e equals MC squared he
also did this famous work on Brownian
motion which I don't talk about it all
in 1906 1907 he did a very important but
very underappreciated work on
quantization of energy i'll explain a
little bit about what that means and
quantum theory of specific heat of
solids that was actually incredibly
important not very well appreciate
1908 did work on a wave particle duality
I'll come back to that briefly and he
did a failed theory quantum theory of
light then 40 from 11 to 15 he works on
the famous general theory of relativity
space is curved gravity as a result of
the curvature of space I talked very
little bit about that in the book but
it's a turning point in his life because
two years later he becomes a worldwide
celebrity when it's confirmed or
actually four years from 1915 and then
in 1617 he comes back to quantum theory
talks about how it's a random theory
which is going to be a theme in quantum
theory and then his last great work in
quantum theory is about quantum
statistics working with this unknown
stimulated by this unknown Indian
physicist bows and then finally in 25 26
quantum mechanics is proposed as a final
theory by Heisenberg Schrodinger and
born and Einstein has a response that
i'll tell you about i've already hinted
he obviously doesn't like it so this is
about twenty years from nineteen oh five
to nineteen twenty five i would say his
contributions briefly summarized here or
about eight nobels worth six of which
are in quantum theory we're going to not
count these minor contributions and
relativity equals m squared and general
theory of relativity so so it's
interesting because those actually are
such spectacular insights that if you
just take that away you still find you
know six phenomenal contributions to the
foundations of physics okay so I'm going
to just tell you we're not going to have
a big long lecture here I'm going to
tell you a little bit about this idea of
quanta of light and quantization of
energy and then just a word or two about
randomness and quantum statistics and
and then a few words about Einstein as a
person at the end okay so one more thing
about Einstein as a person to get us
into the science when he was in barren
he formed this little kind of study
group which they humorously called the
Olympia Academy they were basically
unknown struggling Bo starving people
this cut
a beaked was a mathematician mathematics
student as Marissa Levine was a
philosopher and Einstein this ritter von
Stein was a funny nickname that Conrad
had beat gave him and all their their
letters have this kind of frat boy
character to it which I found very
amusing to give you a little censored so
first these guys were really struggling
it sort of reminded me of the opera la
boheme instead of having you know the
philosopher and the musician and the
artist instead you've got the
mathematician the physicist and the
philosopher starving but pretending that
they're going to do great things and one
of them actually does do historic things
so this is a little little sort of
souvenir from that time Maurice olivine
drew this cartoon of Einstein as the
president of the Academy surrounded by
links of sausage which is all they could
afford and here's a very grandiloquence
dedication to him in Latin which
translates partially as man of hatching
gun which is etching densest that's his
ancestral part of swabia he was from
expert in the noble arts steeped in the
revolutionary science of the cosmos
bursting with the knowledge of natural
things powerful guide to those fabulous
molecules so they were they were having
a lot of fun and unfortunately hobby got
a job moved away and saw lavigne got a
job moved away so in the miracle year
the the Academy wasn't meeting and we
only have this one letter that Einsteins
sent to Hibiki to know what he was
thinking that because he wasn't writing
to anybody nobody knew him right so he
announces this and this is one of the
most famous letters in the history of
science it's in early 1905 and it starts
with starts with dear hubby such a
solemn air of silence has descended
between us that I almost feel as if I am
committing a sacrilege when I break it
now with some inconsequential babble so
what are you up to you frozen whale you
smoked dried can
of soul why have you not sent me your
dissertation don't you know that I am
one of the one-and-a-half fellows in the
entire world that would actually read it
with pleasure you wretched man okay so
that's how they talk to each other so
and then he says I promise you for
papers in return the first deals with
radiation and the energy properties of
light and is very revolutionary the for
study is still a mere concept the
electrodynamics of moving bodies by the
use of a modification of the theory of
space and time so of course this is
relativity theory and this is the
beginning of the quantum theory of light
and there are two other really good
things in there too so he just kind of
tosses this off in this sort of
sarcastic letter to a beaked this is the
famous volume of an a lender physique
where it was three of the papers were
published max planck who will feature in
our story shortly the great german
physicist was the theory editor and and
looked at all these papers unfortunately
we don't have any referees reports and
no one knows what they actually said God
that they got published that's all we
know okay so very revolutionary this was
the only time we know that Einstein
actually said a work of his was
revolutionary so I will be focusing on
that so why was it revolutionary so what
did we know about light in 1905 oh wow
so did I hit that could not be
okay Wow okay so what did we know about
light well we knew that it was a
traveling wave of electric and magnetic
energy and it traveled at the speed of
light so all these waves travel with
this 300,000 kilometers per second and
the theory of this was put forward by
the great Scottish theoretical physicist
james clerk maxwell and i talked a
little bit about him he's a very
interesting character in the book and we
can characterize the wave by its
frequency which we call new and it's a
wavelength which is inversely related to
the frequency by via the speed of light
and this leads the idea of the
electromagnetic spectrum which goes from
radio waves at megahertz up to x rays at
10 to the 18th cycles per second and you
and this is our electronics now in at
the end the gigahertz range sure many
people here know about and actually
there is no lowest and highest frequency
it's an infinite spectrum light being
there in the middle at hundreds of
terahertz and the other thing that was
going on at the time is that people
realized that matter is continually
emitting an absorbing radiation okay so
that we're emitting and absorbing some
kind of radiation all the time and in
fact due to our temperature it's roughly
this infrared frequency that we emit and
absorb and that's what you see with the
night vision goggles okay so the person
that was working on this in 1900 was Max
Planck here he is on a particularly bad
hair day but it's the only 1900 picture
that I could find of him and and and the
technical term for this was black body
radiation I think most of you know that
that black is the color that sort of
absorbs all all colors all incoming
colors so if something's black is going
to absorb the blue light and then it's
going to thermal eyes the light and
re-emit typically at infrared which you
can't see so it was red here but
actually you wouldn't be able to see
this
okay and the question was for the
temperature of the black body how much
energy did it Amit as radiation for a
given temperature how much and what was
the energy density plank thought he knew
the answer in 1899 that it was basically
something conjectured by Wilhelm vigne a
few years earlier now Clank thought he
had proved it he wrote a paper saying it
must therefore be concluded that the
veen distribution for this energy is a
consequence of the second law of
thermodynamics so that is the strongest
assertion you can make the second law of
thermodynamics that entropy always
increases is one of the fundamental laws
of physics that has never been shown to
be violated and plank thought that he
had proved venes conjecture so now this
talk I'm giving for with without a lot
of equations and so on well here I'll
show you one more slide and then I'll
get back to that ok so he said this in
1899 in about nine months later his
colleague curl bomb was presenting their
latest data for how this energy that
they were measuring coming out of the
black body depended on temperature and
frequency this is a plot of the energy
density versus temperature and the data
fall on this nice line but the vigne
theory that plank had committed to goes
like that so it doesn't agree at all so
this was a theorist worst nightmare
because he had predicted something that
was clearly in contradiction with
experiment and also he had not said it
was an approximation it said that it
followed for the most fundamental laws
of physics so I found this a classic you
know gee I wouldn't want to be him
situation being a theoretical physicist
myself this is your you're really your
worst nightmare you know you've
obviously just done something wrong
right I mean that's that's that's so
what's he going to do he's standing in
front of the same people to which he
made this claim nine months earlier so
what he does is he kind of grass around
and tries to find a way to get this
linear dependence and I'm not going to
go through this whole slide because I
don't want to go for too long this is
the one technical slide so let me just
skip through
I'll come back to it if you're
interested but this is the the law
mathematical law for the energy density
of the blackbody radiation thermal
energy law and it turns out that in two
limits you one limit you get veen law
when you look at high frequencies the
other limits you get this thing which is
linear in temperature which is called
the rayleigh law and that's essentially
at low frequencies or high temperatures
so so the data i'm showing you here is
the rayleigh limit where it's linear in
temperature and in the vigne limit it
isn't so so he guessed this answer he
guessed this formula for technical
reasons that I can go into and it was
able to explain the data but he didn't
have any justification ok so he guesses
the right answer and he says look I'm
kind of at a loss but this is what I
think the right answer is and then two
months later he says after some weeks of
the most strenuous work of my life some
light came into the darkness ok so so
this is what he proposes ok that for
some reason the matter that's absorbing
radiation can only exchange energy in
little little increments of H times nu
now nu is the frequency and H is this
thing that he introduced called Planck's
constant which is the signature of all
things quantum so what's so strange
about this idea well energy in
macroscopic physics why am I doing this
I'm trying to hypnotize you ok so what
plank was doing was he was imagining
that the atoms that were absorbing the
light were little Springs with charges
on them that was just a sort of a model
that he had called them resonators and
this was his statement that the
resonators could only change their
energy by a discrete amount but if you
think of a macroscopic resonator like a
pendulum this is the closest thing I
have to a pendulum thank you dear then
you know the the energy in the in the
pendulum depends on how much you stret
you know you displace it right as more
energy now if i displace it higher
kalyan and it looks like the energy that
I can give to this pendulum obviously
there's some biggest energy it will
start doing that but but it looks like
it's continuous because I can just kind
of you know displace it from its lowest
energy state by any continuous amount so
it looks like energy should be relayed
continuous just the way space and time
are continuous so to say that this is
true is really an insane crazy
conjecture that's the point okay and he
says that what I did can be described
simply as an act of desperation by
nature I am peacefully inclined and I
reject all doubtful adventures that's
what he said but however he didn't
reject this one however he hints then
maybe this is a provisional hypothesis
maybe we can get rid of this then he
says nothing more about it for the next
five years doesn't publish anything in
the book I say it's like a family that
agrees never to discuss again a
traumatic episode so so the only person
that actually is mulling this over in
those five years essentially is this
young patent clerk in baron albert
einstein and stimulated by plank he
actually challenges the wave paradigm he
writes this paper on a heuristic point
of view concerning the production and
transformation of light it's heuristic
because it's not a full theory it's not
a full mathematical theory and he begins
it by saying it seems to me that the
observations regarding blackbody
radiation and the photoelectric effect
can be better understood on the
assumption that the energy of light is
distributed discontinuously in space and
that it considered light consists of a
finite number of energy quanta localized
in space which move without being
divided and cannot be can only be
absorbed or emitted as a whole so this
is essentially light acting like a
particle not like a wave okay and this
has a clear connection to Planck's
quantization because if light can only
be absorbed in units of H nu then the
energy of the atoms can only change that
way ok but he also points out that if
you don't make this hypothesis you just
use classical physics you find a total
disaster that radiation sucks all the
energy out of
matter and we all freeze to death and I
have a long discussion of this thing
called the ultraviolet catastrophe in
the book which doesn't happen because of
quantum mechanics okay but there was
obvious problems was saying that the
light was made up of particles okay we
knew that light was a wave and how do we
know that well waves interfere this is a
you know water waves which are being
produced here by an oscillating rod or
something like that and you see there's
these calm regions where the peaks and
the troughs are cancelling and then
there are these very you know uneven
regions where the peaks and the troughs
are adding up that's the phenomenon wave
interference okay so what was the medium
for light if it interfered because water
waves are disturbance in a medium that
was a problem the controversy raged in
the first half of the 19th century I
want to tell you a little anecdote about
the spot of outer go so in 1818 the
French Academy of scientists Sciences
announced a competition for the theory
of the properties of light and this guy
a Gustav Rennell proposed a mathematical
theory and the famous mathematician +
song who you may have heard of the
Poisson process he thought that this was
nonsense and he derived what he thought
was a contradiction so he proved that if
I had this round object and I looked in
its shadow that if the wave theory was
right there would be a bright spot at
the middle of behind in the middle of
the shadow and that Tim was a proof that
obviously they weren't ways because
obviously that was wrong but for nail
had a friend ok this friend was named
Francois out ago and he seems to remind
someone of the most interesting man in
the world because in addition to being a
great physicist he also was the Prime
Minister of France he was the person
that abolished slavery in the French
colonies and he was a military hero and
so on so he was the most interesting
physicist and he actually did the
experiment and yes there is actually a
bright spot in the middle of the shadow
the round thing has to be very smooth or
you don't see it so it took some effort
to see it but it's definitely there so
that was you know this sort of
tastic experiment that showed that the
wave theory was right even when it
looked contradictory and then it became
routine you could send light through a
slit and see these interference bands
and so people made up a medium for light
to travel in called the ether you
couldn't see it but that's what life
supposedly traveled in and they invented
a disruptive technology radio which
already was working in the 1890s based
on this theory so if we knew anything
certainly in physics in 1905 we knew
that light was an electromagnetic wave
okay so so Einstein said that the
photoelectric effect gave pause made you
reconsider this point of view what's the
photoelectric effect well you have
imagined that you have ultraviolet light
or purple light incident on something it
could be a black body some piece of
stuff if it's a metal what you find is
instead of it being just absorbed and
re-emitted as radiation actually comes
out as an electron that's called the
photoelectric effect okay and you can
measure that with the voltage or current
that is then detected photocurrent okay
and the observation was no matter how
intense the incident radiation no
electrons would come out if the
frequency of light was too low you
needed a certain frequency threshold to
see any photo current now why was this
so it doesn't make sense in the wave
theory that the more intense the wave
the more energy it should shouldn't
matter what the frequencies but in in
the particle theory you say that the the
light wave is actually a train of
particles each having energy H nu and
one of them interacts with an atom at a
time it can give all its energy to that
Adam if the frequencies too low it's not
enough energy and the electron jiggles
around but it doesn't come out because
it's bound to the atom right but if it
has high enough frequency and high
enough energy then it'll get knocked out
so that was his explanation for how you
could explain the photoelectric effect
with some new type of physics of quanta
of light but there were no good
experiments for ten years and no
significant theorists believe dine Stein
was right for probably more like 20
years ok
so in 1913 Einstein gets recruited to
Berlin he's now become in physics a
celebrity this is a much later period
like 1929 that is one of the people this
was the Godfather of German physics and
chemistry at the time Walter Nernst
that's Max Planck there's Einstein a
little older this is a Milliken and from
huawei they all won the nobel prize in
physics but it's a little bit later
anyway these two guys went and twisted
his arm to come to Berlin and get him
into the prussian academy of sciences
and they talked about how he was the
greatest physicist since Newton and
Galileo except they had to apologize for
one thing he may sometimes have missed
the target of his speculations for
example in his hypothesis of light
quanta but that can't really be held
against him so this thing which we now
see as the foundation of modern quantum
theory was the thing they had to
apologize for ok so what about the
photoelectric effect well this guy
Milliken actually was a great
experimentalist you probably know about
the Milliken oil Drop experiment he
really wanted to do this experiment so
this is how you do the experiment you
have an arc lamp you put it through a
prism to get the violet end of the
spectrum through a slip it hits this
thin metal foil and then you measure the
electrons coming off and there's a
current there but they also have this
little grid of metal and if you charge
that up negatively you can actually stop
the electrons from getting to the
collector that's called the stopping
voltage and according to Einstein's
theory that stopping voltage should just
be a straight line versus frequency so
he did this experiment it took him 10
years did this experiment and this is
what he found perfect straight line and
when he measured the slope I'm sorry I
should have said that the slope is H
Planck's constant universal ok he guys
guess the straight line calculates the
slope those of you that recognize
Planck's constant will see it's Planck's
constant ok and he says I spent 10 years
of my life testing that 1905 equation of
Einstein contrary to all my expectations
I was compelled to assert its
unambiguous experimental verification in
spite of its unreasonableness since it
seemed to violate everything we
about the interference of light okay so
this is how Einstein got eventually won
nobel prize in 1922 i can tell you more
about that if you're interested because
this was unambiguously correct so which
is it then what did Einstein say is he
saying the lights of particle or is it a
wave well Einstein in 1909 said very
clearly clearly that it was both it is
therefore my opinion that the next stage
of development of theoretical physics
bring us a theory of light which can be
regarded as a fusion of the wave theory
and the emission or particle theory so
that was the beginning of this wave
particle duality of quantum mechanics I
think I'll skip over this a little bit
this is the quantum theory of the atom
in 1916 where Einstein talks about the
fact that when an atom emits a beam of
light that that this is a random event
there's no cause for it and he struggled
with this a lot he says the weakness of
the theory lies and the fact that it
leaves the time and direction of the
emission of light to chance nevertheless
I have full confidence in the
reliability of the course I have taken
this was 1917 but then in nineteen
twenty he's still kind of mulling it
over he's unhappy he writes to his
friend Max Born this business about
causality gives me a lot of trouble I
would be very unhappy to renounce
complete causality and that's a feature
of quantum mechanics uncaused events ok
the last thing I'm going to say of just
a brief word about in terms of science
is in 1924 Einstein got just in the mail
a paper from an unknown physicist such
endre nath bose from india he reads this
and he understands there's a deep
insight in there which we call
indistinguishability and i have another
prop here to explain indistinguishable
ax t so i have two coins here and oh if
I toss it let's see what I get ok I got
two heads let me do it again
okay I'm gonna fudge this okay there I
got a heads in the tails so if I keep
doing it what's the probability I'm
going to get a heads in a tail half
exactly because there are two ways there
for outcomes two ways i can get heads
and tails and only one way I can get
head says or tails tails well what was
buried in boses paper was the idea that
atoms aren't like that okay that if I
interchange two electrons I can't count
that as a separate state so if these
were quantum coins the probability of
getting heads and tails there will only
be three states heads tails would be one
state there would be one state of heads
tails tails head and then heads heads
tails tails and that probability would
be one-third so so that changes all your
counting and you're counting determines
entropy and all of physics is then
changed obviously I cannot go into the
details of that but trust me this
discovery of this new type of statistics
that Adams behaves is it leads to an
idea of quantum condensation
bose-einstein condensation six Nobel
prizes are related to it because it
underlies super conductivity and other
things so it was a huge breakthrough and
mostly due to Einstein not Bo's in 1925
Einstein gets a letter from shredding
her that the shooting are the famous
Erwin shooting her and shredding are
saying you've just done this wrong
because you've done your statistics
wrong Einstein says no no thank you hair
colleague I have made no mistake let me
explain it to you and now here this is
what i love this is the same example
that I just gave you you see it right
he's got the four cases classically
where you have the two interchanges here
there's only one case you see in BOS
statistiche ax so you know this is
Einstein explaining both statistics just
the way I did to you ok so a Schrodinger
is inspired by this in the next year he
and Heisenberg independently event the
modern form of quantum theory he gives
Schrodinger says my theory was
stimulated by de Broglie and by brief
but infinitely far seeing remarks by
Einstein ok there they are that's
shooting around the right
eisenberg on the left they were both
well Heisenberg was very young okay but
Einstein after studying this for half a
year comes the following conclusion
quantum mechanics is very impressive but
an inner voice tells me it's not yet the
true Jacob the theory produces a good
deal but hardly brings us closer to the
secrets of the old one that's his funny
way about talking about nature some
people think it's God but we're really
talking about nature here i am at all
events convinced that he does not play
dice that's the famous quote and he just
stuck by that for the neck the rest of
his career now we have the old guy there
he says all these 50 years of conscious
brooding have brought me no closer to
the answer to the question what are
light quanta of course today every
rascal thinks he knows the answer but he
is deluding himself ok so now before I
close just a few comments about Einstein
as a person what was he like he as you
can tell he had lots of joie de vivre a
sense of humor enjoyment of life here's
a quote from a friend his sense of humor
was readily apparent when someone said
something funny the laughter that welled
up from the very depths of his being was
one of his characteristics which
immediately attracted one's attention
obviously this independence he was a
secular human humanist early proponent
of universal human rights sympathetic to
the underdog hated militarism loved
music as you probably know very well
rounded intellectual knew about
literature and so on he was very
charismatic he was adored by his friends
he was very attractive to the opposite
sex a lot has been written about that so
I only hint at it in my book and here's
a great quote that I like the strongest
impression one gets is of stunning
youthfulness very romantic reminiscent
of the young Beethoven and then laughter
erupts and one is faced with a student
so that's a description of Einstein at
age 43 here's a picture of Einstein you
can see all this he's loving music he's
kind of looking at the opposite sex he's
having a good good time that's in 1913
and okay what was the nature of his
genius well he was a deep thinker but I
would not say it was a mathematical
genius he was more of a conceptual
genius he was intensely curious about
nature he made this modest claim
I have no special talents i'm only
passionately curious i don't think
that's true i already said that he had
this talent for unification and
simplification very flexible thinker i
have a chapter called entertaining the
contradiction where he's really
beginning to think you could have
particles and waves coexisting which
nobody else did at the time and he was a
very insightful critic including of
quantum mechanics i could go into that
more science was his existential
philosophy that's the last thing i want
to say so here's a couple of coats from
him physics is an attempt to
conceptually grasp reality as it is
independently of it being observed and
then to his friends he would say do you
really believe the moon exists only if I
look at it and this was his critique of
quantum theory that it was always
talking about the observer so he didn't
like that okay and finally he said I
believe with Schopenhauer that one of
the strongest motives that leads men to
art and science is escape from everyday
life with its painful crudity and
hopeless dreariness from the fetters of
one's own everyday desires a finely
tempered nature longs to escape from the
personal life into the world of
objective perception and thought that's
what he was trying to do with his
science his rejection of quantum
mechanics reminds me of Beethoven in the
end of the force of the ninth symphony
in the final act after the first three
he says nick de diez atena you know not
these tones we need something different
and he tried for the rest of his life
unsuccessfully to complete a harmonious
resolution so thank you for your
attention
okay so the floor is open for questions
I have very have a question that I had
before I listen to this addiction okay
if men never saw light or knew the
existence of light what would be the
fantastic the reason why I'm asking this
question is planck's constant comes
because we see light and when we see
likely to still party to the DC bit like
and then but the lights I can't with
lights property is it better than the
plans function and then you give the
certainty and everything that comes to
plan sponsor so the reason why I am
asking this question is the quantization
and the theory of what if we can change
if you find another medium of detecting
objects that is nearing their light or
sound it is faster than no that's
actually that's that's probably not the
right way to analyze it so Heisenberg
tried to explain the uncertainty in
quantum mechanics by saying every time
you observe you disturbed and there's
this famous microscope experiment where
you know you're trying to observe the
atom and the light bump said and it
moves off so you don't know where it is
after you've observed it but now we've
come to understand that that is not the
right picture and actually Einstein
played a big role in proving that that
couldn't be the right picture because
now we know things that are far away and
don't actually disturb each other can be
effected through you know observation
air can affect something over there so
we now say that things really just are
uncertain has nothing to do with whether
we disturb them and in particular
Planck's constant is just the scale at
which you can stop resolving things you
have to worry about the fact that the
electron is spread out and so on so if
the the if you measure things in the
right units you'll say I really have to
worry about the fact that the electron
can go this way and that way through the
wire and interfere whereas if you know
the scale of billiard ball I no longer
have to worry about that so it sort of
really doesn't have to do with light
anymore than it does with matter yeah
where your stuff yes okay so this is
rather technical right so so the paper
was about the following in the
intermediate stage of quantum theory
bore and then arnold sommerfeld came up
with a prescription called the bore
Sommerfeld rule where you basically
looked at a class as if an electron
we're moving up with Newtonian mechanics
and but you said the only orbits that
were allowed were orbits where when you
went back and forth the action
accumulated which is something you
measure in quantity in classical
mechanics the action is the thing that's
minimized to determine the it's a
non-local property of the trajectory
which determines which which in quantum
mechanics has to be quantized to be
equal to an integer times H so you have
these classical trajectories and then
the only ones that are allowed by
quantum mechanics are those where you
have an integer number of values of H
bar when you go along the complete one
traversal the trajectory yeah this
problem that with chaos you can have
trajectories that never kind of clothes
on themselves in a nice simple way that
are pseudo random and therefore you
can't construct a bore Sommerfeld theory
of chaotic motion even though it's a
classical motion its newtonian motion
and so Einstein brilliantly found a way
to generalize bore Sommerfeld to more
complicated motion but he also
identified the problem of chaos and said
there's this other type of motion which
plank RA has found where clearly there
aren't enough constants of motion and
you won't be able to do this we don't
know how to solve that problem and
that's the problem we're still trying to
solve in two thousand right that I was
working on so there's some partial
solution but it's it's a and the
interesting thing is that the same
formula that Einstein derived in 1917
was read arrived by a mathematical
physicist Joseph Keller in the 50s
people had forgotten about it and there
was a guy from Berlin fritz
ryka who had known Einstein and when
Keller showed him the formulae said SATs
reminds me of something said Einstein
did and it turned out it was really the
same same thing but Keller didn't
understand this thing about chaos vs
regular so he actually his papers not as
good as Einstein's paper so that's what
I was explaining in that you said there
was no operable no units in the
electromagnetic spectrum yeah I just
thought that there will be some minimum
wavelength just like related to maybe
I'm constantly on set to principal way
you just can't get some wooden within
modern you know quantum mechanics
quantum field theory etc there is no
limitation it's you know somewhat
related to photons having zero mass and
so on however you know people in string
theory we don't have a quantum theory of
gravity they do conjecture you know that
there might be some scale coming in you
know that the so-called Planck scale
it's tiny tiny but you know within the
current theory there is no limitation
well it's not always easy to generate
waves at arbitrarily long wavelengths
and so on but
yeah so see how braces because it also
has to your teacher being held and put
your scene but you have many
conversations around the nature of the
intersection of creativity and
technology and specifically sciences and
the different approaches sometimes to be
very classical in its kind of Lagos and
putting together saben together solid
states in the creative and art spaces
it's much more common to have people
that process information don't say
intuitively but not verbally spatially
when we talk of the sciences they want
to put this in like a genius level but
it's not it's much more common in other
states are you seeing a change in a try
grippos thinking of Einstein as a person
who processes information pull signal
from noise intuitively networks backward
to the initial causes because that's how
we've done the problem solved but that's
okay that's not very comfortable for
traditional science are you finding a
ship in students and this type of
approach how can we stimulate this in
stem without saying it's magic or genius
there's action can we convert my stem to
steam introduce Arts and creativity to
eval be sleeps in lateral thinking it
seems to be the things that create these
eight o'clock sit down well I think the
I think the thing that I find very
impressive in reading carefully
Einstein's reasoning is his flexibility
you know the fact that he was actually
able at the same time he was working on
relativity which assumes the classical
theory of light he was able to propose
this modification and you know even the
greatest physicists of the time we're
just saying look look interference it's
obviously wrong is obviously wrong it's
obviously wrong and he just persevered
with it so you know this ability to
suspend your you know your critical
faculties a bit and entertain the
contradiction was something that
impressed me in his thinking but you
know he was a conceptual thinker he
really you know the general relativity
arose because he was troubled by the
fact that or he was aware of the fact
that you couldn't tell the difference
between acceleration
and the you know and the acceleration of
gravity you know the same thing that
Galileo was studying that didn't matter
how big the the rock was it fell at the
same rate neglecting friction so so you
know most of his things he had a very
clear concept which is I would say is
almost a verbal concept not a
mathematical concept which he then
filled in bit by bit over the years and
when he tried to go totally
mathematically mathematical and look for
unified field theory in the last part of
his life last 20 years he made no
progress at all nothing he did there has
actually survived
yeah so I'm curious if Einstein er if
the current theory holds that there is a
line at which a particle is too large
and can no longer show with particle
duality um so right now we see no
boundary and this actually gets to
something really interesting which I
didn't say a word about so actually my
department we're very involved with
quantum computing and trying to
demonstrate macroscopic quantum behavior
in in circuits so that you can do
calculations with quantum algorithms and
some people here may know about that
definitely in Microsoft as a whole I'm
sure you have real experts but so so you
know one of the things that it's
relatively easy to see wave particle
duality in a light particle like the
electron that's why we found that in the
20s and with an even an atom which is
not that big by our standards is being
compared able to on the scale of seeing
that kind of interference effect and in
the 90s we figured out how to cool atoms
to 10 to the minus 9 degrees above
absolute zero and then sure enough we're
doing atom interferometry and one of my
former colleagues is flying these things
in in you know helicopters and in
submarine putting them in submarines
because the interferometer can then
detect changes in the gravitational
field so you can find where there's an
oil deposit or maybe a underwater
mountain or something like that using
these interfere metric methods anyway
that's what they're used for it but that
was a case where suddenly we could take
a much bigger object and see quantum
effects the same things happening with
these circuits we now have circuits
where and a current of electrons of say
100 nano amps can be simultaneously
going that way in this way at the same
time which is a quantum effect so we're
pushing that boundary and nobody's found
a point at which quantum mechanics fails
although there are very reputable
theorists who think there might be such
a boundary
and if there is a boundary white white
what is the reason they think I mean is
that you I haven't heard this is the
first time of character that it was in
Macbeth particles but based on size
stops going Joanna tea um so I'm not
sure what people's reasoning is one
person that it certainly was very
interested in this is a Nobel laureate
Antony Leggett who's one of my heroes
and you know initially when he proposed
these macroscopic quantum experiments he
was one of the leaders he thought they
would show quantum mechanics was wrong
but so far they've all showed the
quantum mechanics is right and I saw him
fairly recently so I said well what is
the scale what you there has to be some
new constant of nature nature that says
you can't do this so I actually since
I'm kind of a believer in quantum theory
and I just think the world's that way
then I don't have an argument for what
the scale would be but his argument
certainly the the simplest argument is
just we've never tested it so it could
be wrong whereas you know we've tested
all the chemistry all the solid state
physics has been tested in a thousand
interconnecting ways so that you
couldn't really find something wrong
with it or everything else would be a
mess too
yeah with the latest findings today how
would we explain the double slit
experiment differently to say 50 years
ago I mean do we have a different
definition of observation or how would
you explain that experiments right now I
mean I don't people struggle very hard
for some words that make it seem more
intuitive that these you know that
things can sort of be and going in two
different places at once and until you
do interaction with it and I don't find
any of them helpful at all I certainly
don't find many worlds at all helpful
that annoys the heck out of me you know
like every time the electron is measured
this way there's one world where it went
that way another world okay but the
thing that has come out very clearly
from all this work in quantum
information physics and computing and so
on is that observation doesn't have
anything to do with people you know
observation is an interaction with
another degree of freedom and so if you
it doesn't matter whether our person
measures it can be measured by the
cosmic microwave background and that's
why Schrodinger's cat could never really
be because a complex living organism is
interacting with so many things that it
doesn't show quantum effects it's always
being measured if you like and if you
isolated it from the environment than it
would die so that you don't have a dead
cat so you know in a practical sense
Schrodinger's cat is never going to
happen probably know about Schrodinger's
cat most people here know about
Schrodinger's cat yeah
so I find that somewhat comforting but
it's still a bit of a puzzle we still
argue about it and and you know there's
this other school that dominated for a
long time called shut up and calculate
you know but now it's under siege
because of all the quantum computing
work which makes you actually think
about these things again what is what is
your most irritating pop culture
misrepresentation of quantum theory
today thank you for that question um
actually I'll just slightly divert it to
but it's very close to your question the
thing that bothers me is that quantum is
famous for the weirdness right so it's
famous for the cat that's half alive and
half dead and the you know and and stuff
like that whereas end and quarks and
Higgs bosons and so on but actually
quantum is the basis of all our
technology it that's what I said at the
beginning so you know those you know the
laser and the transistor and all that is
fundamentally requires quantum to
understand and so when I tried to write
you know people were saying no one's
going to read this book because quantum
is going to scare everybody away but if
you're going to talk about quantum you
have to talk about the g-wiz going
backwards in time beginning of the
universe etc you know because that's
that's all they want to do is be amazed
and I don't want to amaze people I want
people to say isn't this amazing that
people figured this out but now we
understand it right now we understand it
you could understand it read the book
you can partially understand that
somewhat understand it so you know I
hate the g-wiz this is just confusing
and you can't understand it part of it
we all work with quantum theory you get
used to it it's beautiful it's it's
truth I mean I personally have predicted
things in quantum theory that were never
measured people went and they measured
them and they worked so that is the most
exciting thing you can have as a
theoretical physicist and so you feel
this is true this is beautiful you get
very excited about it and it's kind of
amazing the first time yeah this
here what we always asking about finding
ways to describe it in ways that might
consider intuitive do you think that
more will be discovered about the fabric
of the universe that helps people to
understand the impersonal way that is
into the first do you think maybe that's
just not
I mean this is of course wildly
speculative so we'll new things about
the fabric of the universe lead us to
have a more intuitive understanding of
these things that seem very odd and I I
mean okay wildly speculative answer just
gut feeling is that when we figure out
what dark energy is and so on it's just
going to be worse not better that says
my guess you know because it's some
particle that doesn't even interact with
matter but has gravity you know so it's
not going to have any connection to
anything we understand on earth you know
so I feel like none of these things that
we will get a deeper predictive
understanding but not an intuitive
understanding and it gets back to my
point that the fact that human beings
can understand something that's you know
a thousand times smaller than a human
hair no it's actually like a 10 to the
fifth times smaller like an atom not
even counting quarks okay I'll if you
throw them in then it's a you know a
billion times smaller and so on that's
amazing we weren't even didn't evolve to
do this it's incredible that we got this
understanding and the fact that Einstein
kind of got the key ideas you know of
about eighty percent of it is also
astonishing this one man who was so
brilliant in this other related sphere
of relativity yeah online question if
I'd say was to win the Nobel Prize or
something besides the photoelectric
effect what one piece is quantum and
boats discovery should it be four well I
mean okay so I have two candidates so
one thing that everybody agrees is
spectacular but it's a little more
technical is this Bose Einstein thing
that I talked about at the end because
it's kind of one of the fundamental mini
body affects the month fundamental
features a matter at low temperature
that shows up everywhere and underlies
so many phenomena in quantum physics and
the fact that I mean that's just like a
slam dunk we've given like six Nobel
Prize since for manifestations of that
so why didn't he you know okay so that
that one is kind of ridiculous I have no
idea why they didn't give him the Novo I
think they just said he doesn't care
anymore that's not you know he's got it
he doesn't care he obviously
care one of the stories I tell you in
town the book is that he he got a note
like in September of 22 and saying you
know you really should stay around
because something might be happening in
stockholm in december and he had planned
to go to japan and he wrote back me said
sorry i'm going and then he got a
telegram during the voyage at some point
saying he had won the nobel prize he
didn't mark it in his travel diary you
know sorry it says played quartets you
know on you know me 12th or something
but it doesn't mention got one nobel
prize today so so you know he didn't I
mean you know obviously he was an
insensitive to it but at that point you
know so so that certainly the
bose-einstein but that's a more
technical thing thing that's a little
bit more conceptual is and really
underappreciated is this thing I just
alluded to which is in 1907 he he really
said energy is really quantized and I
told you that plank fudged it he really
didn't want to say that at all he didn't
say it till after Einstein so the idea
that energy is quantized really came
from Einstein no.67 and this is also
what TS kuhn the famous historian
science says so I didn't I've not the
only one saying this and and and so that
thing which is sounds very kind of
mundane specific heat of solids turns
out to be something that absolutely
clearly should have won the Nobel Prize
and it's and and when people write about
Einstein see I'm the only they're mostly
astrophysicists or high-energy
physicists they probably don't know that
much about the specific heat of solids
but that's my field that's big so so you
know it's under appreciated so that
those two I would pick as you were
researching his life was there a big
surprise or something that you
misconception that you had about him
that turned around that is a great
question well I think I expected it to
be harder to follow his reasoning I
expected the kind of stereotype of this
is the genius and you can't understand
him he just has these leaps to be the
case and what I found was he was like
completely compatible with the way I
think about physics that very logical
and and and just you know someone that
you could really get inside his head and
and see him thinking about it and
appreciated it so i think the kind of
you know incomprehensible genius thing
even I as a theoretical physicist I
thought I would encounter more of that
and so maybe that that would be one
thing the fact that he was so popular
with his friends and so like because
there are these stereotypes another one
I'll give you two you know that maybe he
was a little bit cold or a little bit
even this Asperger's rumor which clearly
cannot be true but he was actually just
this kind of life of the party guy who
loved puns and jokes and had a sort of a
little bit of a dirty mouth and that's
another gang my last code maybe not the
best one was when he so he finally gets
his first job in 1909 I mean he's taken
people for years after 1905 to actually
give him an academic job in Switzerland
and he writes to his friend I am finally
an official member of the guild of
so that's the kind of a joke that
go and I actually told that to a german
physicist friend of mine and he
absolutely refused to believe it he said
oh it's miss translate must be
mistranslated I don't really speak
German so so i win i got the german
thing and the word is Helen which sounds
a lot like hard to be so I think it
wasn't mistranslated so the fact that
you sort of the more even more of the
life of the party as opposed to this
kind of gentle philosopher particularly
as a young man
was the other thing on the personal side
that those two things I guess